good evening thank you for joining us we
start then with that breaking news on
the partygate investigation sky news
learning the senior civil servant sue
gray and boris johnson had a private
meeting to discuss the handling of her
long-awaited report earlier the prime
minister who has been in wales today
said number 10 would not put pressure on
her over the report live straight away
then to our deputy political editor
sam coats must have made for a very
interesting conversation this summer
yes for five months we've been waiting
for the report by the top civil servant
sue gray into what went on at the height
of the pandemic inside whitehall
we saw the police finding issuing 126
fines
next week and time and time again we
have been told that the independent
civil servant
sue gray will deliver her verdict now
sky news can reveal tonight that sue
gray actually met boris johnson uh it
took place about a month ago a little
bit potentially a little bit more longer
even longer than that
details are very very sketchy but
unsurprisingly nick there is a huge
effort underway uh tonight to try and
downplay the significance of this rather
surprising meeting people telling me
that it's perhaps routine it was an
update that the point of the meeting was
for sugray to update the prime minister
on where the metropolitan police were
with their work what was going on with
the various investigations and with the
uh uh by the police and where uh they
were with the interviews uh there are a
few scratchy details that are uh uh
uh uncertain uh in some cases disputed
it's not clear
potentially they talked about whether or
not photographs should be included in
the final report i understand that is a
live issue right now unresolved
potentially we could see some images
when the report is published next monday
tuesday or wednesday
but it is unclear uh exactly the details
or indeed the date beyond the fact that
the meeting took place before parliament
towards the end of april voted to refer
boris johnson to the privileges
committee now why does this matter well
it matters for two reasons first of all
just because the existence of a meeting
that hadn't been publicly disclosed
hadn't previously been talked about i
think will raise some eyebrows uh there
was no attempt uh by number 10 but by
anyone else to push information about
this uh meeting out proactively so the
fact that it has been revealed tonight
by sky news i think will be
an embarrassment in of itself the second
thing is that number 10 have been very
clear and boris johnson has done this as
well that it is completely up to sue
gray exactly how she
goes about
her report the kinds of things that she
includes and the judgments about how to
do it were all down to her now as i say
some dispute about exactly what was
being said in that meeting all sides do
agree uh that boris johnson and sugray
didn't talk about the judgments that
she'd be making in that
report but it appears according to some
that there might have been some scope
for a discussion about the nature of the
poor of the report and how she was going
about some of her work now that does rub
up against some of the more recent
statements by danning street uh so
sketchy uh but important
what did sue gray talk about when she
met boris johnson why did she meet him
uh how who initiated the conversation
and what does this mean for questions
about the independence of the whole
process all of those now on the table
tonight over after the revelation of
that meeting
all right so many thanks indeed for
updating us there
some coats